-It derails my work.
-I know. I'm sorry.
-I just --
I'm trying to look out
why you would choose
to hurt me so deliberately.
-No, I -- I mean, I just wanted
to hang out with my friends.
-Right.
-I wasn't --
-So you want to be here
with them at my expense?
You're incredibly selfish.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Anna Kendrick,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And now for
a complete tonal shift.
-It was a real tonal shift,
yeah.
-It brings the room down even.
-And, now, that's a comedy?
-Oh, it's about psychological
abuse. It's hilarious.
You guys.
-Now, this -- I do want
to ask one more question
about directing
before I ask about this film
where you were an actor in
and you directed yourself.
You are an actor....
but what did you --
Did you learn anything --
I think, over the years,
directors would love
to know the kind of notes
actors like to receive.
And you having been
on the other side first,
how did you find
giving those to actors was?
-I mean, I thought -- Well, you
know, I hoped I was okay at it,
but I did find that I would
just give really direct notes.
And I would give somebody
a note,
and then like three people
from the set, from the crew,
would be like, "I didn't know
you could say that to an actor."
I'm like,
"Okay, we are like children.
We're barely people. I get it."
But, like, there's this feeling
that we're going to, like --
like explode into dust
like "Avengers Endgame"
if you say, "Can you just
do it a little faster?"
That's all. Like, that's all
I said to people, was like,
"Hey, maybe just
a little quieter or something."
-Well, that's a helpful note
for an actor, right?
-I agree. I agree.
-They know exactly how to do it.
-Like, I feel like sometimes
if somebody just wants me
to do something specific,
they tell me this long story
about my character's grandmother
or something,
and I'm trying to decipher,
like,
"Did you just mean quieter?
You can just say it, babe.
I'll be good."
-So, in this film,
you play a Canadian.
You shot this at a remote cabin.
And I'm wondering,
when you play a Canadian,
do you try to affect
a Canadian accent?
-I think nobody told me to.
Nobody wanted that from me.
But I did --
There were a couple times
where I would, like, try
to sneak in a, like,
"Oh, you're having trouble
with that, Eh?"
[ Laughter ]
And, like, the entire cast
and crew was Canadian,
so they're like, "Baby, no.
We don't need to do that.
We don't need to
do that today, no."
-What was it about this
psychological sort of thriller
that drew you to it
in the first place?
-Yeah, I mean,
it's a really challenging movie,
and it's about emotional abuse,
which is a hard thing
to even put into words,
let alone put in a movie,
and I think the movie's not
really what you expect it to be.
It's almost got this, like,
mystery structure
where it unfolds really slowly.
And people have been
really kind about the film,
and I think a compliment
that I've been getting recently
is that people will talk about
it and they'll be like,
"And I loved, like, you know,
almost how little dialogue
there was."
And you can only get
that compliment so many times
before you're like,
"Is it my shrill voice?
Is that the problem?"
You're like, "I loved the part
where you shut up.
It was, mwah, your finest work."
-I'm sure that's not
what they were saying.
This is very exciting.
You went to a wedding in Italy,
but you did not go to Italy
to go to a wedding.
-Okay, so, yeah.
I went to Italy this summer.
It was my first time.
Italy's great.
-Italy's great.
-Have you guys heard
about Italy?
I hadn't, because
I am not well-traveled.
But it was amazing.
And I ended up in Florence,
and this --
The actor Jay Ellis,
who's from --
we love from "Insecure"
and "Top Gun." Lovely guy.
I had met him like twice.
And the place I was staying
in Florence --
across the street,
he was having the, like,
night-before reception
for his wedding.
And he found out
I was across the street.
He was like, "Well, you have to
come to the reception.
It's just so crazy
that you're here right now."
And so I was like,
"Yeah, of course, of course."
And I went, and then all night,
he's saying,
"You should really come
to the wedding tomorrow,"
which I was like, "No.
So sweet of you to offer.
I understand you feel obligated
to be polite and offer,
but of course not."
And he kept insisting,
and I was like,
"No, no, I don't want to be,
like, a part of a fight
that you and your wife get into,
in five years where she's like,
'And another thing!
You invite what's-her-face
the night before the wedding."
No. No.
And as I'm heading out,
he asks me again.
I said,
"No, that's so sweet of you.
No, thank you.
I couldn't possibly."
And I said, "Well, you know,
I heard the dress code
is earth tone,
and I didn't even pack
anything earth tone."
And he said, "Well, Anna,
you're rich as [bleep],
so go buy something."
[ Laughter ]
Which -- So now
I'm the cheap ass [bleep]...
-Yeah.
-...if I don't go buy something
to go to the wedding.
So the next morning,
I, like, went to Zara --
'cause I'm very rich --
and I just bought,
like, the first thing I found
and I went to the wedding.
And I did cry like a baby,
even though I was
totally crashing the wedding.
Like, you would have thought
that this is my oldest friend
in the world, I cried so much.
-I think it's very --
it's allowed that you cried.
You're in Florence, Italy.
It's a very romantic place.
Obviously, you'd just
blown a lot of money
on an outfit you were
never going to wear again.
Congratulations on the movies.
-Thank you.
-Both of them.
And it's so nice
to have you here in person.
-It's always so great to be
here. Thank you for having me.
-We love having you.
Anna Kendrick, everybody.
"Alice, Darling" opens
exclusively at AMC Theaters
nationwide on January 20th.
we'll be right back
with John Larroquette.